herr gysi es kam nicht bei allen so gut
an was sie da ihre partei zum jubiläum
hingelegt haben müssen sie etwas
zurücknehmen nein natürlich nicht jetzt
habe ich mir alles gut überlegt und ich
weiß dass ich junge gibt die sich ärgern
über meine gegnerschaft zum doppelpunkt
zum großen ii und zum sternchen aber ich
will nicht die schreibweise sondern die
verhältnisse verändern
und ich glaube dass das für die mehrheit
der partei gilt und die anderen
konzentrieren sich auf die schreibweise
und ich will mich etwas schreiben was
ich nicht sprechen kann aber darum ging
es mir gar nicht es ging mir darum dass
eine partei in der existenzkrise sich
nicht um solche fragen kümmern kann
sondern sie muss sich oft fünf
schwerpunkt fragen konzentrieren die ich
genannt habe und die zustimmung war ja
insgesamt doch sehr groß bei ihnen aber
es gab auch ganz schön applaus für die
kritik an ihrer rede dass sie das fast
überhaupt aufmachen dieser gender
debatte wurde hier kritisiert muss das
denn sein wenn man zum jubiläum
gratuliert dass man das dann quasi als
geschenk nicht ich habe ja gar nicht
gratuliert sondern ich habe von unserer
existenzkrise gesprächen und dazu gehört
auch dass wir uns permanent mit solchen
nebensächlichkeiten beschäftigen und
eben nicht mit den fragen um die es
wirklich in unserer gesellschaft geht
und das wollte ich ihn gott also ich bin
eigentlich mit der reaktion insgesamt
sehr zufrieden aber das ist ja immer
welche gibt die unzufrieden sind das ist
mir auch klar gibt ja noch ein paar mehr
es gab auch leute die versucht haben per
antrag hier sozusagen ihre rede zu
verhindern hier werden auch flyer
verteilt von einer kleineren
gruppierungen dass man sie aus der
partei wirft wegen ihrer positionierung
in eu und nato fragen hat sich die linke
von gregor gysi entfernt oder gregor
gysi von den linken weder noch wofür wir
streiten müssen ist das wieder deutlich
wird was mehrheitsmeinung sind und was
minderheitsmeinung sind die sind ja
damit auch nicht durchgekommen und ich
habe ihn ja die ganzen probleme der
außenpolitik sucht zu erklären gerade
anhand des beispiels von schweden und
finnland ich habe die frage nicht
beantwortet ich habe gesagt wir müssen
die frage beantworten und ich bin sehr
gespannt wie die reaktion darauf
verloren
stichwort aussenpolitik das ist
natürlich einer der knackpunkte hier auf
dem parteitag lang haben das gesagt auch
sie haben nun auch in der vergangenheit
immer viel verständnis für die position
russlands aufgebracht habe noch im
februar im bundestag gesagt warum
gewährt man putin keinen
sicherheitsabstand sie haben ihre
meinung da aber jetzt auch korrigiert
haben sie auch gesagt war das auch für
sie zu spät oder ist die einsicht
sozusagen bei ihnen aus ihrer
perspektive noch gerade rechtzeitig weiß
ich nicht natürlich jetzt schon gar
nicht beurteilen dazu findet alles noch
viel zu schnell statt natürlich hat man
vorher die sicherheitsinteressen
russlands nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt nur und das ist der punkt
das rechtfertigt nicht den
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg die usa
hätten so was auch nie zugelassen
russische raketen haben wir mal in
mexiko und auf kuba aber die antwort
darf niemals krieg sein sondern man muss
dann immer versuchen über diplomatie und
anderes zu reden dann hat guten jahr
drei vorschläge gemacht und der westen
am statt 3 gegen vorschläge zu machen
und verhandlungen anzubieten sagten und
freundlich nein nur und das ist für mich
das entscheidende
alles was falsch gemacht wurde vom
besten in bezug auf china und russland
nichts davon rechtfertigt auch nur im
geringsten den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg und wenn man den scharf
verurteilt wie ich darf man nicht gleich
ein aber dahinter setzen weil das dann
die kritik sofort wieder relativiert das
haben sie in ihrer rede auch so gesagt
an gerade am anfang als die der partei
die leviten gelesen haben gab es was
haben sie selbst glaubt vereinzelte
buhrufe ist das überhaupt mehrheitsfähig
was sie hier ansprechen also fast alle
sind aufgestanden und haben minutenlang
beklatscht das scheint doch noch mehr
als fähig zu sein ok also sie sozusagen
ein positives fazit ganz so mehr von der
realen mars ab wir wissen erst am
sonntagabend wie der partei tag
insgesamt gelaufen ist da bin ich jetzt
nicht zu früh eine beurteilung abgeben
meine rede sollte ihnen die chance auf
zeigen die wir haben ob sie genutzt wird
kann ich ihnen noch nicht sagen wenn wir
über die chancen reden haben sie denn
den eindruck dass jetzt bei den
kandidatinnen und kandidaten die zur
wahl stehen in den parteivorsitz dass da
die chance besteht die linke wieder auf
kurs zu bringen oder stehen sie
sozusagen hier davor dem sozusagen zu
scherbenhaufen auf ihres lebenswerks
nein also wir werden am schluss zwei
vorsitzende haben wir haben eine große
verantwortung ich werde mich jetzt zu
den personalien nicht äußern also ganz
keine favoriten oder es ihnen selbst
wenn ich sie hätte würde ich sie nicht
äußern und noch aus der zeit
und und das problem ist nur dass wir
dann tatsächlich eine führung benötigen
um die partei auf die wesentlichen
fragen zu konzentrieren damit für die
gesellschaft unser stellenwert wieder
deutlich wird und dass damit auch wieder
die zustimmung zu dieser partei wächst
die zustimmung soll wachsen sie haben 15
jahre lang jetzt passieren lassen ein
wenig auch in ihrer rede sie haben aber
auch schon heute wieder vorleben klima
der denunziation gesprochen haben sie
übrigens 2012 ja schon mal gemacht muss
man rückblickend auch sagen müssen sie
auch sagen uns ist es eigentlich nicht
gelungen die partei zu einen das ist uns
nicht gelungen die demonstrationen zu
überwunden aber jetzt merken alle im
unterschied zu 2012 das dass uns die
existenz kosten kann und deshalb bin ich
das deshalb habe ich das heute noch
einmal gesagt weil vielleicht die eine
oder andere sich jetzt doch überlegen
wird ob sie diesen weg weitergeht oder
ob sie das vielleicht einfach bleiben
lässt ich habe viel kritik eine grün
aber eins können sie also die streiten
sich nicht weniger als wir aber man
liest sieht und hört so gut wie nichts
davon in den medien das können die
wesentlich besser als wir also zum
fünfzehnten geburtstag der linken
empfiehlt gregor gysi ein bisschen sich
was bei den grünen ab zuschauern fielen
da aber nur ein bisschen was den rest
bitte nicht ja alles klar haben wir
verstanden danke dass die phoenix waren
herr gysi